LEIGHA JARETT: Hi, and welcome
to our session on building
an interactive machine learning
application using both Vertex
AI and Looker.
I'm Leigha Jarett,
and I'm a developer
advocate here at Google Cloud.
And I'm also joined by my
colleague Sara Robinson.
Before we get into
the details, let's
talk about why you might want
to build an interactive data
science application
for your team.
Well, we know that business
users of all different types
need access to the results
of machine learning models.
And we really want to
eliminate that bottleneck
so that they don't need
to go through a data team
to get access to the results.
We also want to make sure
that our data science
application has an
easy-to-use and simple UI
so that people of all
different technical levels
are able to interact with
machine learning models
and get the data that they
need to do their jobs.
Finally, we want
to provide guidance
onto how business
users should interpret
the results of machine
learning and also take action
on them so we're making sure
that machine learning is
having a real influence on
business decision making.
Now in this
presentation, we're going
to talk about how
Google Cloud can
help you build these data
science applications.
So let's pretend
that we are working
for a marketing department
of an e-commerce company.
I might decide to create two
different models in Vertex AI.
First, I'm going to create
a classification model
to predict whether or
not different users who
see an advertisement are
likely to make a purchase.
Then we're going to create
a time series forecasting
model to predict our different
revenue so we can accurately
measure the lift
of those campaigns.
Now, in order to train
our Vertex AI models,
we're going to supply data
that's coming from our BigQuery
data warehouse.
This gives us the
scale and reliability
that BigQuery offers
so we're able to store
and transform and prepare our
data for machine learning.
Finally, we're going to use
Looker to actually create
a custom application
that our business
users can interact with.
Using Looker's
Extension Framework,
we can customize the UI
exactly for our needs.
And we'll enable our users
to interact with this UI
and have the results of
their interactions sent back
to Vertex AI to create new
predictions from our models.
Now I'm going to
pass it off to Sara
to talk more about Vertex AI.
SARA ROBINSON: Thanks, Leigha.
Let's start by looking at what
Vertex AI is at a high level.
Vertex AI is our end-to-end
managed machine learning
platform on Google Cloud.
It's designed to help you with
every step of your machine
learning workflow, and
it's designed for people
regardless of ML expertise.
So whether you have deep
experience building custom
models, or you're just getting
started with machine learning,
we have ways that
you can use Vertex
AI to add to your machine
learning applications.
So here we can see an overview
of all the different products
that are included in
Vertex AI for each phase
of a typical machine
learning workflow.
We're going to focus
just on a few of these
in this presentation,
starting with data sets,
showing you how to
link data in BigQuery
to a data set in Vertex AI.
Then we'll look at how
to train models in Vertex
and get predictions
on those models.
And throughout
this presentation,
we'll be focused on models
trained on tabular data
to build both a classification
and a forecasting model.
Let's start by
looking at data, which
is usually the first part of
any machine learning workflow.
So in Vertex AI, you start
by uploading a data set.
And you do this by
selecting the type of data
you're working with, along
with the prediction task
that you'll be solving.
In this presentation,
we're going
to be working with
tabular data, but we also
support a lot of
other data types.
And if your data doesn't fit
into any of these categories,
don't worry.
You can still use Vertex AI to
train your own custom models.
Next let's look at
a decision framework
that I use to help
customers figure out
which parts of Vertex
AI are right for them.
The first question to
ask is whether or not
you have your own training
data to use for your model.
If the answer is no, we have
a set of pre-trained APIs
that give you access to
machine learning models
that have already been trained
on lots and lots of data
that you can access
via a REST API.
For this presentation,
we're going
to be focused on the right
side of this flowchart.
We're assuming that you
do have your own training
data that you want to use to
train custom machine learning
models.
The next question
to ask yourself
is whether or not you're going
to be writing the model code.
And whatever the
answer is to this,
we have tools to support
you on Vertex AI.
We're going to be focused
on AutoML for training,
but you can also use Vertex
AI to train your own custom
models built with any
machine learning framework.
Let's take a closer look
at AutoML for training.
AutoML is a tool that lets you
train state of the art machine
learning models in less
time, because you're not
required to write any of that
model training code yourself.
All you do is upload
your data to Vertex,
select the columns
that you're going
to be using for training,
along with the column that
has your label or the thing that
your model will be predicting.
You press a Train
button, and Vertex AI
will iterate over different
model architectures
to find the best one suited
for your prediction task.
When your model
is done training,
you'll then get access to
detailed model evaluation
metrics along with
feature attributions.
Once you have a
trained model, there
are a couple of options
for how to get predictions
on that model.
The first is you can
deploy your model
to an endpoint in Vertex AI.
And endpoints live in
the same place in the UI
whether you train the model
using AutoML or your own custom
model code.
You can also access both types
of models via the Vertex AI
SDK.
You can split traffic
between different models,
and you can also customize
the machine type where
your endpoint is deployed.
And if latency is
less of a concern
and you have a lot
of test examples
that you want to
get predictions on,
you might want to create
a batch prediction job.
And we'll show how to
do this in the demo.
To create a batch
prediction, you
can do this either in
the Vertex AI console,
or via the Vertex AI SDK.
And you'll specify
where your data
is that you want to get
batch predictions on,
and then where you want
Vertex AI to write the results
of those batch predictions.
In the demo, we'll be creating
a batch prediction job based
on data we have in BigQuery.
And without further ado,
let's take a look at a demo.
In this demo, I'm
going to be showing
how to train two different
models using data
from BigQuery.
We'll train a classification
model, along with a time series
forecasting model.
And we'll use AutoML to
train both of those models.
When the models
are done training,
we'll look at some
evaluation metrics,
and then we'll see how we can
create batch prediction jobs so
that we can then visualize
the results of those model
predictions in our
Looker dashboard.
Let's go to the demo.
We'll train two models in
Vertex AI using our retail data.
First, we need to import our
data from BigQuery into Vertex.
There's a direct integration
between Vertex AI and BigQuery.
Here we'll create a data set.
This data set will be used to
train a tabular classification
model.
We want to import data from
BigQuery, so we'll select here.
And this is the
BigQuery table we
want to use to train our model.
It's some data on
orders, and we'll
use it to predict whether or not
a customer will make an order.
We'll enter that
BigQuery table here.
And now we're ready to
train a model on this data.
We'll train our
model using AutoML,
which means that we don't
need to worry about writing
any of the model code.
Our target column is made_order.
This will tell us whether or not
the customer made a purchase.
Here we'll select the columns
we want to use for training.
Here we want AutoML to maximize
the accuracy on our model
for the less common class.
We're doing this because the
percentage of customers who
made an order in our data set
is much smaller than those who
didn't.
And with that, we're
ready to start training.
We'll follow the same process
to train a forecasting
model to predict sales for
different item categories.
Here we're using
seven days of data
to predict what the
category sales will
be seven days in the future.
Now that we've
trained two models,
let's see how each one
performed, starting
with our classification model.
Here we can see that 77%
of the time our model
was able to correctly
predict when a customer would
make a purchase.
We can also see
feature importance.
This shows us which features
signaled our model's prediction
the most.
In this case, it looks like
the advertisement category
was the most important
indicator of whether or not
someone would make a purchase.
With our trained model, we can
now deploy it to an end point
to get online predictions.
We can also request
batch predictions
by creating a batch prediction
job, either in the UI,
or programmatically
via the Vertex AI API.
The result of our
batch production job
was written to a BigQuery table.
For each row, we can see
the percentage likelihood
that a purchase was made.
Here it looks like there is a
71% chance that the customer
made a purchase.
Let's also take a look
at how our forecasting
model performed.
Here we can see some evaluation
metrics on our model.
When we kicked off
our training job,
we specified that we'd like
test predictions written
to a BigQuery table.
Let's take a look
at that table now.
Here we can see the sales
predicted by our model
compared to the actual
sales on that date.
Now let's see how to
create a batch prediction
job, looking at one window
of our time series data.
When we're formatting
our data for prediction,
we'll pass it a BigQuery
table with sales
data for our seven-day
context window,
and then we'll provide
the date we want
to generate a prediction on.
For this model, it's
seven days in the future.
We'll leave the sales
value for that row blank,
since that's what
we want to predict.
We can get predictions on as
many seven-day time series
windows as we'd like.
Here we're just showing
one for demo purposes.
When this batch
prediction job completes,
we'll see the resulting
predicted sales value
for the date that we specified.
In our Looker
dashboard, we'll be
able to visualize the
predictions resulting
from both of these models.
LEIGHA JARETT: Thanks, Sara.
So now we understand
how to actually create
models in Vertex AI and
even hit an end point
to get new predictions.
But how do we extend
these capabilities
so that non-technical
business users
are able to interact
with Vertex AI
and analyze the results
of those predictions?
This is where Looker comes in.
So you may already be familiar
with Looker's architecture.
Looker enables you
to create a data
model, your single
source of truth
for all of your
different metrics.
And it sits directly on
top of your data warehouse,
so BigQuery in our case.
For the data
science application,
we might create a model
where we're actually
defining metrics associated with
the prediction results coming
from Vertex AI.
This will allow our business
users to explore the results
and create visualizations
or dashboards,
and even operational
workflows to take action
on those results.
But how do we
actually enable them
to interact with that endpoint
and create different inputs
that feed into Vertex AI?
This is where the Extension
Framework comes into play.
Looker's Extension
Framework allows
you to create custom
JavaScript to control
the UI for a custom application
posted in the Looker
environment.
So the great thing about the
Looker Extension Framework
is it handles all hosting,
authentication, authorization,
and gives you access
to Looker's APIs,
ability to embed
Looker components,
like dashboards and looks.
And also, we have a set of
open source UI components
to really accelerate
your time to value.
This diagram really helps
put it into perspective.
If you want to go and
build a data science
application on
your own, you have
to take care of all of that
stuff outside of Looker.
But with the Extension
Framework, so much of it
is taken care of for
you under the hood.
So just to put these
two pieces together,
first, we're going to create a
dashboard using native Looker
technology.
We'll model the
prediction results.
We'll explore them,
and create a report
that business users can use.
Next we'll use the Extension
Framework to actually customize
the UI so it's purpose
built for our models,
and so that users can
control the inputs that
are fed back into the
Vertex AI prediction job.
So let's actually see a demo
of all of this in action.
I'll jump into my data
science application
so we can see how a marketing
person would interact with it.
In Looker, I can navigate to
my data science application
from the left side panel under
the Applications dropdown,
or if you're using an
earlier version of Looker,
from the Browse dropdown.
Now I can see my
custom-built application
for the marketing team to
create targeted advertisement
campaigns.
On the left-hand
side, marketers are
able to control
inputs to the model,
like selecting users
from a certain traffic
source, country, gender, age,
and previous purchase history.
They can also specify
what type of advertisement
they're planning to run.
For example, here
we're predicting
if we fed an advertisement
campaign for accessories
through a search channel.
On the right-hand side,
we have our dashboard
to actually analyze the
results of the model.
So here we can see that
when we ran the model,
we fed in over 65,000 users
that had an average age of 53,
a certain average
prior spending habits,
and we can also see their
geographic location.
Scrolling down, we
can start to analyze
the results of the batch
predictions from Vertex AI.
So here I can see that
2.6% of our user base
was expected to make a purchase.
We can also use that
information to calculate
our predicted campaign cost
if we just targeted that 2.6%.
And we can slice our
likelihood to make a purchase,
so that predicted measure
coming from Vertex AI,
by other fields in
the user information,
like how many orders
they previously
made, what their
traffic source was,
and what their age group was.
Next, we can look at the results
of our time series forecasting
model.
So to actually see what our
predicted revenue if we don't
do anything is for
the next seven days,
and see that compared to
prior historical sales.
Now this dashboard is just
like any old Looker dashboard.
So as a marketer, I can
explore from here, drill in.
So I might want to
explore and actually send
these users who we predict
to make a purchase off
to an external
application to target them
for that advertisement.
Now that we understand how
a marketer would interact
with this application,
let's start
thinking about how
we actually went
and built this application.
Like we said earlier, we built
this using Looker's Extension
Framework.
So what we did was created some
lightweight custom JavaScript
to control the UI that
we're seeing here.
On the left-hand
side, I actually
used Looker's
components to create
each one of these inputs.
Let's see what one of these
components might look like.
For example, the
CheckboxGroup component
is used for our first input.
Now, I'm a data person, and
not a front end developer.
And although I did have to learn
a bit of JavaScript and React
to get everything
working appropriately,
most of the
application was built
leveraging these
components and working off
the Extension Framework code
templates that are available.
Now if a marketer wants to
change the inputs to the model,
for example only focusing
on people in the US
and maybe seeing
what would happen
if we ran an advertisement
for jeans, I can click Run.
And I'm going to have
to verify my identity
to make sure I have permission
to run the Vertex model.
And then in the
Extension Framework,
my code is actually going to
send this information to Vertex
to create a batch
prediction job.
Now before Looker
actually talks to Vertex,
it uses the Looker API to
create a BigQuery table that
contains one row for each person
in that audience we created
to predict on.
And you can see we're going
to have the jeans search
campaign, which is the
fields that the user entered
to actually see
what would happen
if we ran a certain
type of advertisement.
And then the details of
the BigQuery table, we
can see that it's set
to expire tomorrow
so that we aren't storing too
much unnecessary information.
And also, it's named
with this long hash.
And this is basically a unique
identifier for the prediction
that we're running.
Now if we open up
our extension code,
we can see that after
the BigQuery table has
been created, it's time to make
our Vertex prediction call.
Here we're using
Looker's extension SDK
to create a POST request
to Google Cloud platform.
And in the input we're going to
specify things like our model
ID, the location where
this needs to run,
and also our input data, so that
BigQuery table we just created,
and our output
BigQuery data set.
Since batch
predictions sometimes
take a few minutes to run,
we send the user a message
on Google Chat when
the results are
ready with a link to review.
Here we also include the
same hash used earlier
to bring the user back to
the results of the model
so that they can
use the dashboard
to investigate their results.
The dashboard itself is just
a regular old Looker dashboard
that's embedded
into our application
using Looker's embed SDK.
So just like previous
Looker API calls we made,
this requires just
a few lines of code
and no authentication needed.
We use the embed methods to
pass in values for the filters
based on what the user
has entered on the left.
You'll also notice that we have
a parameter for our table name.
This is the hash that was used
to identify the prediction,
and it's what's going
to be used to make sure
that we're leveraging
the right table that
stores the results of the latest
prediction results from Vertex
AI.
Now the great thing
about this entire app
is that it was simple to build,
since Looker and Vertex do all
the hard parts, like model
and front end development,
deployment, and authentication.
And my marketers can
interact with machine
learning all on their own to
get data when they need it.
Thanks again for
joining us today.
So we talked about how to
build a complete data science
application using
Vertex AI and Looker.
Sara walked us through the
Vertex AI platform, including
how to create, train,
and deploy models,
and I showed you how to explore
the results of those models
in Looker and create your
own custom application using
Looker's Extension Framework.
So to get you well on your
way to creating your own data
science application, we
have listed some resources,
like Looker and Vertex AI
training courses and labs.
We also included some
other Next sessions
that might be relevant to
what we talked about today.
So thanks again, Sara,
for joining us and talking
about Vertex AI.
And thank all of you
for joining us today.
We hope you enjoyed
this session,
and that you enjoy
the rest of Next 2021.